the video akash was referencing is like
something where you're saying oh i got
paid 500 000 to help the capital right
or something like that
like is that is there any credibility to
that did you have any connections with
the capital right i'm just curious
what don't we know about that i'm glad
you bring that up because the last thing
i would want to do
is attack the us capital and go to super
max prison
um i the way i work is live on air
if i start calculating stuff i'm
exhausted and can't do it i just tell
what happened so yeah
i'm i go to dc this whole nightmare
unfolds this whole thing happens
and i go up on a rooftop that night
as they're attacking people with
flashbangs and there's
hundreds being arrested and total
insanity's happening we'd already rented
this
uh top of a building right above the
capitol to
cover the events that day thinking trump
was going to come speak at the capitol
it didn't happen so the way to tell the
story because this will be definitely
viral
and it's smart for your show to bring
this up period is is to explain the
whole thing
so let's start at the end and then move
back and we can
currently it's a video that gets a
million here a million there 5 million
there
400 000 there when you say it's a viral
video it's every day
trending on twitter for three weeks
straight sometimes number one on twitter
arrest alex jones
alex jones confesses to ordering the
attack on the capitol and they even lie
and go look at this leaked video
i'm up there above the capitol with it
behind me explaining what happened all i
knew to do that day was go report
hey trump campaign called me
three weeks ago and said we need
somebody to fundraise
to set up an event where he's going to
challenge the election at the ellipse
outside
the white house that's a mile and a half
away mm-hmm because converted proper
belief the president the executive
branch has to pay for these events
you've got to get campaign people to pay
for it well trump had no support then
so we wanted to challenge the election
it's all right whether we're right or
wrong
and i'm like wow the president wants me
to do this yeah and so i ended up
talking some people involved they got
the fundraisers
they try to give me the money i go no
here's the money over here it costs 500
000
i get in contact talk to the white house
they want to have a peaceful event
like trump has all the time at the
ellipse in between the washington
monument the white house
thirty thousand people can sit there big
fence porta potties all you know mel
detectors everything
i get there and i've heard this i
haven't talked to trump in months then
and they said trump wants you to lead a
march
to the capitol when this is over
and who tells you this uh i mean it's
people from the white house and
they're coming out of the back like i'm
in the front row and there's trump right
there and they're coming out and talking
to me and saying this
and i go yeah i heard this and then sure
enough 30 minutes to the end of speech
he goes all right i want everybody to
start marching into the capitol
and the secret service opens up the back
thing while he's still speaking i get
let out
pennsylvania avenue is right here
already
there was over a million people they
couldn't even hear trump with the
ellipse even on the jumbotrons it was
tiny
yeah it's like a postage stamp they're
already going down there and i got
security guys with me some of these guys
are here today
and they go hey we we got reports that
they're attacking the police we need to
run
down there and and they're like hey
because my achilles is totally torn it's
one of the problem exercises
can you run and i said yeah i can jog so
we jogged a mile and half
down there so they go hey you need to
stop this because you're going to get
blamed they're smart guys or military
guys
yeah and so i almost said i'm running up
here's the capital there's about 200 000
people are there it's surreal
and i see like people climbing up like
planet of the apes or something over the
deals
i see flashbangs going off and i'm like
300 yards away and a flashbang goes
right in my face
talk about real just like it was like i
was like wow this is real
so i climb up all these chairs and i go
turn back don't go in and stop we're
being set up
and and the trump campaign instead go
around to this side of the capitol by
the supreme court there'll be a stage
trump's going to speech he he was set up
i called by trump's coming here don't do
this
we go the other side there's nothing
there
and all of a sudden the capital is
already surrounding the other side so i
go up the top try to get them down i
tell the police i go
i know you've got a pa system um you
need to get on it they use it the next
day saying you're caught out here to be
arrested
i said you gotta tell them get out of
here or let me tell them i said
somebody's gonna have a ken state it's
on video
sure enough that woman gets killed all
other bad [ __ ] happens so i'm sitting
there going man we're being set up we're
being set up talk about get out of here
don't be part of this
i go back i get up on top of the
building i tell that whole story
uh about how i'm sitting there and no
one would step up for trump
and get the money for the event because
you got to rent the spaces pay for the
cruise
it's like a rock concert and i don't
think trump
set me up he was being set up obviously
where
he goes to have this event he has events
all the time he's told yeah it's ready
for you
at the capitol i should have gone
advanced to check it but it wasn't my
event
when people tried to give me the money i
just put them in touch
with the republican party who took the
money it was half a million dollars
i donated 80 000 of it 87 thousand
whatever it was and so
this is such an epic piece of real
history and then the idea they have like
fbi agents and senators
like on twitter with like fifty thousand
retweets saying jones is gonna be
arrested man he tried to kill her by the
capitol
he wanted this to happen why would i my
right mind want that to happen so
trump did not try to attack the capital
they were set to vote they had the votes
in the senate
for a 10-day investigation of election
fraud but by getting a small part of
this giant million person crowd
500 600 to break through and go in
buy a you know a big crowd it's
dangerous it's a football game nfl game
ends
that's what happened and it was some
real listeners real people
that got hyped up and went in but it was
anti-fun that was there
uh jaden x cnn paid them ninety thousand
dollars
they were saying burn it down let's go
and there were people infiltrated the
oath keepers and the proud boys
who 100 i've seen the videos did mount
up believe they were under trump's
command
through cue accused this you know this
8-chan thing
and it was telling them we later learned
in hindsight attack attack attack
and so through that kind of like larping
or you know like you know those games
everybody dresses up like
middle nights and beats each other
everybody showed up
and out of a million people they tricked
maybe 600 or so to go into the capitol
what happened it was terrible
i'm against it but now they've tried to
blame me for that and yeah
i mean it was in the washington post
they have a criminal investigation open
on me and roger stone roger stone had
nothing to do with it
uh because i remember roger was like i
don't have security for me f this i
might even give a speech
uh he didn't even go to he didn't go the
ellipse that day my wife's like i got a
bad feeling
i'm sick of sitting there i need to pee
let's go back to the hotel and just you
know eat dinner and
eat eat lunch she goes baby i don't want
to go to the capitol don't do this i'm
like
let's just wait and see trump goes all
right start marching the capitol
and so he just got completely walked
into it so did i
and so i don't feel sorry for myself but
i'll be damned though if i'm going to be
framed for attacking the catapult when i
had nothing to do with it
and so it was definitely a set up that's
why q's so dangerous
is that here we are exposing the real
pedophile rings the real new world
order all of it but just like they used
8-chan and 4chan
anonymous boards to hijack real
information
they hijacked what we were doing there
and then turned us against ourselves so
i've learned a lot and i learned a lot
that day
because i had the cue shaman you know
the guy with the horns and you know the
guy dressed up in the in the uh
buffalo outfit or whatever yeah viking
bubble of it
i had him on the day after two days
after it he's like i'm on cloud nine
we're taking back america
trump's going to win we're going to
overthrow the government you know we're
invincible q's real you're not
and i'm like dude you're going to jail
trump's going to be removed
it's over the cue thing because imagine
i trust myself but barely because i
think that's screwy thoughts
i sure makes two of us exactly i sure as
hell don't trust some 8-chan thing
telling me it's secretly the president
i'm like hey uh i know the president i
talk to him
yeah don't be a fake i'll talk to q
that's the president so it's this weird
like
mind control of you've seen like wait
help me understand because a few things
i don't understand um if q
was organizing it but then you have
opposite groups like you have antifa who
doesn't [ __ ] with proud boys or whatever
the case is like how are they both
at this thing at the same time to do the
same
sure anti-foot knows there's going to be
pissed off people
so they are on video putting them with
their black clothing
the the trump gear the blue and red
oh so you said that lighting as trumpers
uh yeah yeah
they know we were all expecting anthony
to come attack us
so there's video of them putting on the
mega gear it's posing but also
then everyone believed that trump was
going to overthrow the government and
that hillary's going to be putting
president gitmo
and the storm was coming okay this was
all over the internet they would let you
push this anywhere
i would try to say no cues fake i'd be
banned
so i knew q was their deal then the
keyboards
this is just message boards yeah yeah
we're like we're going to take the
capital back it's going to happen
and so enough people out of the million
that were there believed that
and they got 600 to attack the capital
so
you got a million people showing up
they're online
so the cue boards tell them that
they are secretly in trump's army they
then attack the building believing
they're working for trump
and alex jones and alex jones and trump
get the blame
where'd the 500 000 go if there was
nothing set up no podium no nothing it's
very bad math but if the question is
good
ask the question again i understand
that's why this is you know i've thought
about this i've got to do 500 thousand
dollars yeah i've got to do a powerpoint
i'll tell you i got to do a powerpoint
point yeah because i know this confusion
confuses me
trump wanted an event to challenge the
election
so here's the capital yeah here's the
white house
here's the ellipse here's the washington
monument here's pennsylvania avenue okay
starting at
seven a.m in the morning running till
like two o'clock
with with trump from noon to two is the
ellipse with porta potties and fences
and
secret service this is the rock concert
yes that cost 500 000 you're saying yeah
to put all the equipment in and all the
[ __ ]
yeah porta potties fences jumbotrons
okay okay
then i'm told because i've talked to
trump in a long time then
and i see people come back from behind
the fence telling me secret service
you're gonna lead the march trump's
gonna meet you there
so i want to know i want a real
investigation of this i don't know what
happened
so here's the capital here we are at the
ellipse
at like one o'clock these times are all
side of my head like one o'clock 12 30
whatever it was
trump goes okay march the ellipse secret
service comes opens the gate
directs me through okay i'm walking out
my camera crew everybody
i'm going to lead a march it's
impossible to leave a march of a million
people yeah
third of them are already going down the
road pennsylvania avenue so here's trump
speaking
here's pennsylvania avenue here is the
washington monument here's the white
house down there's the capitol on my own
halfway yeah
so then i'm asked go lead a thing
trump's going to meet you
i go down the road get there and it's
like war of the worlds
with flash bangs and tear gas and yeah
but you said there was supposed to be
like a stage and trump was supposed to
be there yeah the 500 000
you got told by trump listen i don't try
to go i agree i don't try to micromanage
everything
the 500 000 i was involved in was for
the ellipse
i'm told trump's going to speak to the
capitol i'm not the one but you're told
you're told by trump's people
yeah so then i showed up here today i
didn't know you guys were going to have
these hats or whatever the point is it's
just here gotcha so i knew about the
ellipse
i show up i i'm thinking my wife's like
i have a bad feeling this is weird
you're going to leave the thing they're
telling you also the secret service
opens the gate i go back
well he's still speaking here's
pennsylvania avenue 200 yards away 100
yards away i'm supposed to leave this
it's already like people going to the
capitol yeah they've already heard
troubles going to capital then trump
says we're going to the capitol
and so i start going down the road trump
never shows up
i'm on video going let's go to the stage
it's over here we had a marked deal we
go there's no stage
so not to accuse anyone but if i had to
deduce like
if trump says hey everyone go to the
capitol
and you were told that there's supposed
to be like a big
uh rally speech going on at the capitol
and then trump never shows up at the
capitol
but he organized all his people and told
him to go there and let's fight and take
our country back
isn't that kind of trump leading those
people to go
attack the capital listen that is
absolutely open for discussion
and that's horrible war gaming because
who would like when you're about to get
a vote for a 10-day investigation hold
the election
why would you do that you want to show
your numbers and be peaceful all his
rallies had always been peaceful
they so he he was set up by his managers
by the people that worked for him not
telling him that there was gonna be a
stand down and no stage set up
i listen i'm not god dude you getting a
war like this that's like a general
didn't know what's happening over the
next hill
like old times like a general didn't
know what's really going on you know i
didn't have any idea
yeah i was asked to set up the rally i
had already done two big ones in dc
one that had a million people that had
four hundred thousand so we had huge
events that were massive
that's that's not exaggeration we're
talking about like seas of people share
the video
and so i was like excited just to do
this and i clearly got set up by the
managers of it
who led us into a trap got it so are you
not worried now because you are
outspoken and saying that you were told
there was going to be a rally to the
capitol
and trump and his side is saying hey i
had nothing to do with that
so aren't you no no i said go to the
capitol
so i'm just saying somebody's gonna have
to fall on the sword
yeah but listen i'm trying to explain to
you
this is all public yes i'm sure you're
just like you're not going
here's an edited video of alex jones
here's an edited video of alex jones
artillery right there
here's an edited video of alex jones
saying hey
trump told me to do the rally they're
talking about the ellipse
no one thought about the capitol yeah so
they told trump we've got you a stage
they told me that i just guessed they
had all that gotcha i guess when i came
here today you guys would have a stage
yeah
and then they set us up or maybe trump
did it and like
let me really hurt myself make myself
like an idiot and destroy my chances of
stopping this fortunate election
i don't see a motive there gotcha gotcha
but i mean i listen
you're at a big deal with the secret
service and the porta-potties and
the fences i was just there going
through the line getting ready to get my
sit there and watch the president all of
a sudden he's like
march the capital secret service opens
the gate everything they said
and i believe insiders in the white
house set him up how do you think is
going to end up
i mean you know five people died one cop
two days later and it's a terrible thing
four citizens died
um exactly it's the worst thing in us
history it wasn't
um we saw the fires the mostly peaceful
protests you know in the summer before
that
they're just trying to use this as their
pretext to go after the american people
and use anti-terrorism clauses against
the public and the idea that congress
that was that was involved in this the
idea that congress people they have like
articles was jones coordinating with
congress people and i've had the feds
like subpoenaing my phone records and
like
none of it happened no we were not
coordinating anything i was like my
wife's like i want to go eat this is
cold
and like an hour later and i'm like
flashbangs and not know what the hell is
going on
we had i've been to 50 trump events i've
been i mean i was not expecting to walk
into this yeah
if you could go back and do a different
what would you do i would say oh my god
we can't do this we need to have
security at the capitol we're going to
be set up they're going to provocateurs
we got a million people crowd they're
going out of control and if we don't
have the crowd control
and and and and but i would i wasn't
running the event
i was asked to get the fundraising this
is weird
and all of a sudden these fundraisers
start calling me i was being set up
so i don't know all the different angles
or designs of this but
they wanted to get the whole opposition
there at once you could say well maybe
trump
is really a globalist he doesn't like
you and he wanted to set you up as he
left office i don't think that's the
case
but some weird [ __ ] definitely went on
guys
thank you for answering my questions
thank you remember when you see those
videos
there's hours of me talking about it's
like i did right now they're like
they'll probably take club cereal jones
just admitted
on a major podcast that he
is a fraud and that trump ordered him to
attack and you'll be like you didn't say
that
that's what they did find out what i'm
really saying
at band.video and the evil infowars.com
you